[Music]
so I've been concerned because Finance
has become demonized in the last several
years and decade or two and in part it's
for good reason which is the practice of
finance in many ways is broken we see a
lot of activity that is value extracting
as opposed to value creating and that is
really disturbing and you know that's
not just the financial crisis but we see
it in various parts of finance and as a
management to some degree in banking and
so it is really worrisome that a people
have such a terrible impression of it
and B that we sometimes live up to it
but the truth is that we can't live
without finance and we need to
rehabilitate finance and the reason we
can't is because it is so central to the
modern economy so I think even people
who are really upset about finance have
to acknowledge that it's really central
and we have to make it better it is the
fundamental mechanism by which companies
grow we save we allow ourselves to
potentially borrow to go to college we
say for our retirement and innovation in
general has to be funded so finance is
really central what we have to try to
figure out is how and why it's become so
extractive as opposed to creating value
how do you know whether you're creating
value and what is the recipe for
creating value so you know that sounds
very fancy
in fact I use the parable of the talents
which is a very odd parable from the
Bible very harsh parable in the Bible
which effectively captures the logic of
value creation straight out of a finance
textbook by that I mean it tells the
story of these three servants who two of
whom actually used what they're given
well and one of whom varies his talents
people don't often know that the word
talent is actually historically money it
is now the modern notion is what we now
know think of it as is an ability but
the neat thing about that story is it
maps to the basic recipe for value
creation and finance which is just to be
a little technical you know you beat
your cost of capital you surpass
people's expectation
you do it for a very long period of time
and you continue to grow so that's how
companies create value you know that
little recipe for value creation I show
is exactly what is incomparable to
Talent and in fact John Wesley Mitchell
was the founder of Methodism in his
essay on the parable of the talents
basically says almost the exact recipe
for value creation that kind of comes
out of a textbook which is you know beat
your cost to capital its race and you
know give back more than you take as
long as you can to as many people as you
can and and so on and so forth
so it's actually kind of neat in the
sense of the parable the talents that
recipe or value creation actually maps
to the recipe for a reasonably
reasonably good life so that's one
example that there is like you know the
book is littered with kind of basically
examples like that so one of the
mechanisms by which finance is kind of
gone wrong is they've kind of made it
more complex than it needs to be and so
what I try to do in the book is tell
these stories from literature and
philosophy and history that actually
make the ideas really quite intuitive so
ideally you take a look at the book and
you kind of get a host of ideas the core
ideas of finance but just by reading
stories and I think that's a much more
powerful way for people to understand
finance and in that process of
demystification what I hope will happen
is people will feel empowered you know
they'll understand what finances they'll
understand what finance is doing and so
they'll a be more appreciative of the
underlying functions even if it is
broken today but also feel more
empowered to talk about it and think
about it and confront people when
they're faced with it there are a bunch
of different ideas that are kind of core
to finance the most important one is
risk and insurance which is just to
really try to understand the
omnipresence of risk and then to think
about how all the kinds of things that
pay off in life really the way they're
priced are a function of those risks
that they address and how they are
associated with those risks so that's a
really big idea in finance that
underlies the way we think about
security is another price the way we
think about chunks of corporate finance
and that's a really core idea so for
example to think about risk and
insurance and to think about the
omnipresence of risk I use these two
folks who are really fun this
philosopher Charles Sanders person and
this poet Wallace Stevens so by using
people like that people who actually
really deeply appreciated risk and
insurance but people who you would never
expect to be in a finance book I think
you can actually explore the idea of
risk and insurance in a different kind
of way their various misconceptions so
the first is about risk is somehow that
it is complete randomness actually risk
is something that can be understood
there are patterns and it can be managed
so in fact that is what finances stance
is all about those patterns about those
regularities and then figuring out how
to manage in that world so risk is not
really randomness risk is you don't know
what the particular outcome is going to
be but there can be all these patterns
in life that can actually help us
navigate what seems like chaos so and in
fact that is exactly what insurance
companies do and that's what a lot of
people in finance do is try to make
sense of the chaos of the world by
exploring those regularities and in fact
that's exactly why charles sanders purse
who's this philosopher i mentioned
actually said near the end of his life
he just kept walking around everywhere
saying you know we are all insurance
companies because we are all insurance
companies we are all trying to make
sense of the chaos and he was the
founder of pragmatism and so his recipe
for figure out the chaos was you sample
you try you try everything which is a
pragmatic approach to life it's also the
approach that insurance companies take
so well once you kind of come to terms
with the omnipresence of risk then you
kind of think about risk management and
in particular hedging and one of the
counterintuitive pieces of this is there
are these things that help you manage
risks things like diversification things
like options people get a little
confused about that because they think
they're an end in and of itself like
you're just trying to prevent risks from
affecting you you know in reality those
are instruments which allow you to take
bigger risks right so you can take you
can buy little insurance and then that
allows you to take the
your bets in life so for example and
options people think options as in
financial options are Gamble's you know
they can be but in reality the way we
typically think about using options in
finances has insurance and it's
protection and that protection allows
you to take bigger kind of idiosyncratic
bets because you have these options that
allow you some protection
so risk management is actually a huge
chunk of finance because it allows you
to think about taking even bigger risk
than you might otherwise
[Music]